so much of what entrepreneurship is is
about the climb it's about the journey
it's about identifying those those Peaks
or those Summits that you're trying to
get to and then sometimes when you get
there
come to the realization that hey this is
a false Peak right I've got to go back
down I've got to Trek back to then go
forward and to reach a true Summit so
I'm more or less a sherpa on that
Journey where I'm I'm basically walking
with people and and helping uh guide
them uh on their Journey To Success
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 many leaders today I'm with Patrick
Parker the CEO of saspartners.io Patrick
is an accomplished Tech executive turned
founder with domestic and international
experience and operations custom
software development multi-channel
product distribution and marketing
involving both startup and growth
operations he has bootstrapped companies
he founded to millions of ARR and has
raised Venture Capital to build out
teams to refine product features and
user experiences and to execute go to
market strategies Patrick has built
award-winning products and led major
growth initiatives in both public and
private sectors he is a proven operation
strategist with the track record of
building successful businesses if you
want guidance that you can count on then
you can come to the right place with
Patrick Parker and it was a really
enjoyable conversation talking about SAS
Partners IO thank you very very much
Patrick
foreign
Parker welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you very very much for being here
with me how are you today I'm great
thanks for having me on Micah how are
you good good thank you for joining me
all the way from Lexington Kentucky
talking about SAS partners and looking
at different founder dilemmas along the
way and and what you know what what are
the different dilemmas that Founders
have when they were approaching
different use cases that they may need
whether it be applications websites do
they develop their own software do they
do they work with you and what are the
different options out there so I'm
excited to dive into your brain sort of
uncover the complexity of these
decisions and why they're not
necessarily so trivial and maybe we can
start there Patrick how do you know what
led you to sort of understand that these
decisions weren't so trivial
yeah so really just personal experience
uh in the last five years I've built
five different uh companies and taken
them to over a million dollars in
Revenue each and I've I've basically
systematized uh the entire process so
just trying to build out Frameworks
playbooks things like that that would
basically de-risk all of the the startup
activities uh that come along with
actually building and running a business
and so we're talking about you know
business so and when we're looking at
what tasks plays into it and and sort of
your systemic way of thinking through it
what were some patterns that you've
noticed that that were meaningful here
that that may be applicable across a
variety of businesses and industries
I think the biggest misstep actually
occurs during the startup phase it
occurs when people are trying to build a
product trying to take it to Market I
think there's a lot of missed
opportunities around uh actually
validating the there is a need for the
the service or product in the first
place so a lot of the time that that we
spend working with early stage Founders
is built around validating that software
idea how can you before taking the the
time and spending the money to build a
product understand if there's really a
need for it within the marketplace and
so we go very deep on going through uh
the processes of defining your ideal
clients of working through your go to
market strategy of actually
understanding before you build that
product is there a a need is there a
clear path uh to profitability in the
marketplace and if the answer is no then
going back to the the drawing board
understanding what needs to change
whether that is your messaging whether
that is the the overall offering and the
the pain points that you're actually
trying to solve for those clients and so
we we spend the majority of our time
there because I honestly believe that
out of the 91 of
startups that fail
at least half of those are failing
because they built a product there was
just no need for it and in fact there's
a another statistic out there that says
42 percent out of all startups that fail
fail because they fail to uh actually
find product Market fit and so if you
look at those two statistics together
and you change that narrative from you
know being a statistic from failing uh
when you could have avoided uh that in
the first place then you know it it
changes that entire conversation about
how risky it is to to build a startup
and so it sounds like your your sweet
spot is the early stage Founders that
are pre-product Market fit perhaps even
pre-building their product and so what
what type of model you know from from
your end works and working with them is
it Equity based is it cash based because
at this point the startup is so fresh
that they're basically just starting out
yeah and it really depends on the
opportunity and by opportunity I mean it
means the the idea of the founder shows
if it's a a business where we believe
there's a clear path to building a solid
product to taking it to Market and to to
achieving profitability then in some of
those cases we will actually take an
equity stake we'll build the product uh
at cost
and then we will work towards executing
that go to market strategy in order to
to attract the early adopters and and
start gaining some traction itself so
that we can
take all that social proof that we get
from those early adopters refine the
messaging uh and then use that to
continue growing so sort of your
involvement with the actual software
development phase is that also there or
is it mainly in this strategy and the
validation of the products yeah so at
SAS Partners we're really serving two
customers right we're surveying a
non-technical Founders by actually
building the products uh coaching them
through that entire uh MVP stage or MVP
development stage and then we're serving
technical Founders by helping them with
go to market strategies with branding
with refining their their messaging and
then uh ultimately taking those products
to Market and scaling from there so
we're really focused in in both places
um in addition to that I'm focused
primarily on on coaching right working
with those Founders to understand how to
get from point A to point B and then how
to eliminate the risk uh by using those
proven Frameworks and strategies that
are battled tested that are basically
guaranteed to grow your business
I'm really curious about the the sort of
the anything I've actually with
Outsourcing software hey you know as an
engineer myself I I sort of come into
these situations valuing the ability to
have a coherent strategy internally and
have the product teams and the sales
teams and the marketing and working with
engineering and and I'm always curious
about how you know how it works well
outside
that also scales or is this something
that that is mainly as a proof of
concept to to get traction and to check
the viability of the market how far does
this get you this Outsourcing model
yeah it's extremely scalable and I think
that's why a lot of people prefer to go
that route up front so if you're not
someone especially that has that
technical background like you do Michael
then you're gonna need someone to come
in and build your product and if you
don't have co-founders that uh your
disposal that you trust that have that
skill set then the only alternative left
is to find a company or an agency that
can actually build that product fool you
right and so as as you continue to grow
ideally you want to have all of your
development staff or your product team
and helps right but you've got to work
up to that point so a lot of what we're
doing is building out those MVPs and
then we actually operate under a model
wherein you can purchase developers from
us so we have a project team that works
on those projects
um and if it makes sense for you to be
able to bring those in-house then you
can pay for that team and that team
becomes your chain right right we've
done the hard work of finding those
resources of building out that teams and
essentially you're able to just take
that over promise nonsense and I think
that I'm also very biased you know in a
in this conversation because I'm coming
from from you know more of so when I
think of startups or businesses I think
of these deep tech companies that are
very research focused and obviously
they're it makes sense to have an
in-house r d because that r d is the
company right yeah whereas I think that
what we're talking to the is that the
majority of businesses around the world
that aren't necessarily r d you know
that's not their IEP but it's the
business that they're in it's the
product that they're thinking of it's
the you know it's the Ingenuity of what
they're doing and I guess over there it
does make sense where r d is just one
aspect of of you know their business is
just an enabler it's not VIP
that's it that's it
and so I think
you know kind of to add to that too the
the thing that our clients really like
about the service that we provide is we
we do so much more than just development
right so we've gone above and beyond to
to recruit some of the brightest Minds
uh across different functional domains
so you're going to have everything from
uh marketing uh from products from
customer success and support you can
have everything in in-house so
essentially we are your your business
and technology partner uh and people
have a single point of contact that
they're actually reaching out to to get
status updates on on everything so it's
it's a very frictionless process and
it's something that we've developed over
time and again as you said
in a traditional model where you have uh
your building products and it is r d
based you know that's that's one way of
doing things but for most people if they
don't have access or the financial
backing
um to to have that entire uh functional
domain within house right so the only
alternative that's left is you've got to
have someone else actually build that
product right that makes a lot of sense
can you give me some case studies of you
know some some of the really cool
businesses that you've gotten to work
with and and what that experience was
like for you on a personal level
yeah so one of our one of our first
clients is actually one of my favorite
case studies
um still just because of the the amount
of scale that we were able to build out
within the business but we had a a
registered dietitian come to us that was
running her entire online business
through Facebook right and Facebook is a
great platform for connecting people now
in terms of running a business on
Facebook not so much right because you
get uh algorithm changes you get uh your
visibility kind of tapered with in terms
of of the post and things that people
are seeing uh and then you get all the
other noise and distractions that come
along with uh the cat memes and the the
baby pictures and everything else that
that draws your attention away from you
know what actually needs to be delivered
to the clients right so we ended up
building out this entire software as a
service platform
for this client wherein it basically
automated a lot of her motion daunting
tasks so things like paying referrals
where before she was spending almost 40
hours a month manually sending out
um you know referral commissions to all
of her clients that were bringing her
new business and so we looked at stuff
like that we looked at Service delivery
we looked at uh the product as a whole
to see where we could identify areas of
of adding value and essentially she was
able to scale her business from 600 000
to 3.2 million in less than 18 months
just by automating all of this
processing and now she's working about
10 hours a week in in her actual
business and spends the rest of that
time focused on client Acquisitions you
know so again just a massive growth
story there uh that's that's you know
not unique in terms of or I don't want
to say not unique it's very unique story
that hurts
um but not unique in the sense that we
have so many clients that have now
achieved the same type of results
throughout their Journey with us so it's
one of those things that
you know just having the software that
is tailored to you tailored to your
specific business cases uh it's just a
complete Game Changer in a lot of cases
a massive competitive advantage over uh
the other people that are trying to
steal your clients and and serve the
same clients that you are how how do you
manage communication effectively between
Engineers that you work with the
entrepreneur the business person you
know that they go to one that team that
is then leveraging the software how do
you how do you make sure that the
communication is really smooth what have
you learned about making really smooth
communication on that front
communication is everything so what we
always do which is a little bit
different uh with us usually in an
outsourced model you have a client that
is working with someone from the product
team right where we have all these
different functional domains that we're
also responsible for we have a dedicated
project manager uh someone that is
certified in project management that
actually
collaborates with those clients that
builds out data rooms for them where all
of the uh different project artifacts
live where all of the
um reporting is going to go into where
all the billing so it's very organized
and very easy to find and then there's
regular status calls with those clients
as well that that also include members
of the product team members of the
marketing team all the different uh
functional domains that are focused on
bringing this product to life ultimately
taking it to Market and responsible for
playing the discussion mailing it out
right right well where do you find
yourself in all this
you know where are you here yeah so so
basically what I'm doing I'm think of me
as a sherpa right I love the analogy of
of climbing mountains for entrepreneurs
right because that's so much of what
entrepreneurship is is about the climb
it's about the journey it's about
identifying those those Peaks or those
Summits that you're trying to get to and
then sometimes when you get there
come to the realization that hey this is
a false Peak right I've got to go back
down I've got to Trek back to then go
forward and to reach a true Summit so
I'm more or less a sherpa on that
Journey where I'm I'm basically walking
with people and and helping uh guide
them uh on their journey to success
helping to I do everything from from the
actual product design to uh evaluating
the business model I do so much within
the business so I'm I've got a hand in
everything
um but I usually just like to to
describe myself as a guide on that
journey and if you look at sort of your
day today which which piece of it do you
really enjoy most I mean it sounds like
you get to work on a bunch of different
things and then and you mentioned before
coaching was something that in
particular you enjoy doing working with
with entrepreneurs and and businessmen
and women because you see the change of
thought what you know where really do
you get your own excitement here
that's where I spend the most of my day
so so for me it's it's serving clients
and it is mentoring uh teammates
mentoring employees right so I I get the
the most benefit out of that personally
in terms of working with those clients
helping them solve some of their most
pressing problems helping them you know
find a different lens to look at a
problem in order to find that solution
that they're looking for uh that's a lot
of what I do and then outside of that
just working with teammates uh and and
working with employees to help them
understand that you know that what when
where and why right that are so
important and I think that's something
else that we do really well is the level
of transparency that we have in our
organization uh throughout our project
teams is it's so important to be able to
conceptualize and internalize what it is
that you're trying to build so we're not
just giving them a set of requirements
and saying hey go fulfill this task
right types we really bring them into
the entire process so that they can
understand
why are we trying to achieve this result
right who are we serving uh where do
these people hang out how can we best
reach them all those different uh
questions get answered so that they
actually have a stake in the actual
products as well and could perform at
their best
so if we're looking a little bit into
the future and we're looking at SAS and
we're looking at you know organizations
like SAS Partners so thinking a little
bit more broadly about this industry and
and where it's headed how do you
perceive things shifting over the next
few years
yeah so SAS software is is eating the
world right famous uh Mark Andrews and
quote that I absolutely love there's 25
000 softwares of service companies in
existence today a thousand new one gets
added every year so when you look at the
statistics and and you see the continued
growth within the industry
um it's not going to stop it's not going
to slow down so there's been a lot of a
transition to uh focusing on how
products are built and so there's been a
big push in terms of the emergence of
low code no code Solutions some of those
things that may help non-technical
people actually start out by Building
Products building in VPS
um but we're right in the middle of all
of it you know so the biggest thing for
us is understanding what Innovations are
occurring within the industry
understanding how we can leverage those
to the benefits of our clients
um and continuing to to build out and
scale out in the way that we do and so
one of the other things that makes us
particularly unique uh is in terms of
the way that we handle downtime within
our organization so we have uh what's
called a product studio and when our
developers roll off the products uh or
roll off of our project then instead of
letting them go we keep them on staff
and they start focusing on building our
own products so we identify those
different niches that have a need where
we can insert a product take it to
Market and I think
that's somewhere
um that really gives a lot of
opportunity to our developers it really
helps them understand you know the
process of solving problems uh and of
taking products to Market so they're
going to get a shot to do that
regardless of whether or not they're
working on a client project or whether
or not they're working on you know a
product that we're building at house to
take to Market I love it and I think
that if we look at sort of
how software has been progressing I
think you mentioned those you know the
25 000 software companies but you know
what we need to really realize is that
also companies that are not necessarily
SAS companies you know every every
business requires software today and I
think part of what we were touching on
before was this notion okay does this
mean that every entrepreneur in every
businessman needs to understand software
first mindset well you know the I think
there are some cases yes but but some
cases no and it sounds like what your
company also allows them to do
is to focus on the meaningful pieces
right that are meaningful for them and
sometimes it's not the r d that is the
necessarily the intellectual property
here it's just an enabler
for something much greater that they can
then do with their business is that is
that really sort of the the right way to
look at the types of companies that
would really benefit from working with
you
oh absolutely and a lot of the companies
that we serve they're not in the
softwares of service space at all we do
a lot of custom software we do a lot of
mobile apps right we do a lot of uh of
kind of back-end software that is is
really geared around internal
communication or Service delivery
product fulfillment things of that
nature and so it's really just how to be
able to you know reduce some of the
Redundant tasks that you're you know
stuck with in your business through
automations a lot of it is is uh
modernizing Legacy systems I mean
there's so many different areas that we
touch on a day-to-day basis and so it's
really how can I identify the
opportunities that exist within my
business what can I streamline what can
I improve whether that is a process
whether that is uh different products
that I'm using so
we're a consultants in the the kind of
truest sense of the word right but you
know again we we tend to get focused in
SAS because that's where everyone wants
to build most of the the new
entrepreneurs that we work with they're
planning on taking a product to Market
they want to be able to to service the
masses so in order to do that you know
build sets I love it Patrick thank you
so much this is awesome uh continue I'd
love to continue following your journey
with SAS partners and the different
organizations that I'm sure you'll
continue founding and and I especially
love you know you know your own take on
this you know I'm passion with coaching
these entrepreneurs and businessmen
understanding the different complexities
and intricacies of of where things may
go astray but but really focusing on how
do we make this a really intentional and
so on what we're trying to achieve how
do we validate quickly how do we get to
proof of concept and what are the
different steps that that are good for
businesses and so thank you very very
much and stay safe and stay healthy
absolutely Michael thanks so much for
having me on thank you very very much